hey y'all this is Mon and this is the wi
autocomplete
interview why was mon skin
censored wow they can't handle we're too
hot let's go let's go let's go first
question how to pronounce man skin
correctly
no monin mon skin but no one's ever
going to pronounce it don't even say it
so the new pronunciation it's man skin
or main skin no please main skin is can
what is mon skin genre we just do hot
music horny Rock who is the leader of
monkin it's our singer frontman
sexyo it's the four of us what word mon
skin concer Les is more Les's is more
wise man wants it what is mon skin best
I don't know I would
say for your love for me I'd say I'm
easy but I want to be sleep uh probably
T is mon skin Theon of course we are of
course yes we sold our souls to the
devil that's why our skin is so
good okay so okay what best does
Victoria
d'angeles play a den Electro Longhorn
with a custom star in the Victor Angeles
Arctic monk
is
obsessed do Victoria d'angeles have aop
phobia yeah unfortunately I have really
really bad and it's the fear of vomiting
but now I'm handling it better yeah we
can talk about it but still no one can
vomit in front of for 20 seconds but we
can talk about before every time if
someone was like oh my God I'm not like
No And every time I would uh find out
after that they were vomiting they're
all good at hiding it from me when it
happens that's what we do to take care
of B exactly see we hide our sickness
Victoria d'angeles street style me and
Thomas have a challenge between who is
most stylish so I think this shows that
I am of course the
most let's see your Bo let see my Bo
exactly okay working okay
that's how many tattoos does Damiano
David have first of all I want to thank
everybody because you wrote Damiano
David and not Damu from manin for the
second time in my life I have a certain
name this is a big step for me how many
tattoos do I have I have no idea but
according to internet uh sources they
say like 31 I think I have more that's a
big I don't count it how did Damiano
David learn to sing I never did
how to sing like David there's no chance
you I'm sorry you're just go no no
that's the thing when people do this to
sound I don't know like rock or to try
to sing like me it's the worst that
you can do it sounds very bad you look
very
ridiculous aesthetic ah so now who's the
most stylish so who's the most stylish
even less not style it's just less words
to say like it's more than style it's
aesthetic I don't know what to answer to
this I think Victoria is going to answer
to this later no
wor okay so now the most interesting
part about the most I'm a beat I'm a be
Catan t as a kid how were you as a kid
know how I was as a kid tell us was
actually crazy and now now I'm more
normal now we learned how to you know
deal with people
how to live like a normal life okay
next
drum I'm not actually a good drum not a
capable sorry about that yeah Dr in The
Last Story you had a drum solo I'm
delusional this I also search for cuz I
watched the yes cuz there is this hot
video of you doing the drum solo at the
circus maximum concert and I
watch model well obviously obviously
super come on like right look at him oh
he's so nice it goes without saying goes
without
saying funny moments I'm not a fun
person no but there are
lot there l in our Vlogs in our Vlogs
there's a lot of moments where you're
goofy as or you say like that
doesn't make sense and everybody loves
you to my boyfriend Thomas
Raji isaj a good guitarist the best I
think I think yeah I mean not like a
great guar but think that I can play I
can play top five right-handed guitarist
in the world Thomas Raji the lon are you
the
lon do you feel lonely little especially
in the last per no I'm Jing of course
like we are going to play that song Live
is one of my favorite one too so I think
that it's really great and uh yeah I
really love the allas for
sure
oh this is hard bro I'm scary guys this
one is spicy this one is
spicy like
this I mean cuz it was like um a
nickname that I had during the exfat
period this nickname it means like yeah
the cobra snake but the reality is
because he has a cobra somewhere you
know you can guess you your can guess
why the
go thas r G oh my God personality type
nobody thinks your stylish but they like
your
personality they like your personality
better you're Capricorn it's even better
for sure abely what's your personality
time maybe I'm funny I would say agree
I'm good I am yeah I look great I'm
blonde you're blond I play guitar I'm
cool guys okay let's B mon skin where
does m skin leave will never tell you in
Rome cuz it's the best city in the world
we still live in Rome because we
genuinely think it's the best city in
the world they've been trying to make us
move many times yeah first they tried to
have us move to Milan and we were like
no way and then they tried to make us
move to LA and we were like no way but
now we're like eh maybe 3 months a year
what mon Skin song are you oh my god na
we have to take this quiz ah there's
this is a quiz
okay but like what which song Do You
Think You Are I think Zon I think cool
kids cuz I'm
cool the loneliest cuz I'm sad what are
you um I want to be a slave cuz he's a l
he
hard what are monkin concerts like hot
people
moving why was monkin sensor question
why was asking s why we ask ourselves we
ask question to the prod
why was mon skin
censored well they can't handle we're
too hot yeah okay why are mon skin so
popular you made
us you tell us tell yeah you tell us
exactly okay last question why is mon
skin hat once again we ask you why is
mon skin hat maybe is the reason why
we've got censored so it's a you know a
dog bites his own tail I TOS it goodbye
thank
you that was our last board thank you so
much so much for watching
[Music]
it